sometimes watching a movie isn't enough
you also want to eat that movie that's
why there's movie recipes today were
with chef Victor Albizu at del Campo and
Washington DC we have challenged him
with creating a dish Scarface would
enjoy that isn't a plate of cocaine chef
Albizu has selected a list of essential
ingredients to do just that they are
piquillo peppers and black beans to
represent Scarface's black stalks that
ends up stained red squid ink it's the
same color as Scarface's heart and basil
because you just can't forget Al Pacino
is Italian no matter how hard he tries
[Music]
some scarface scarface oliver stone
wrote the screenplay actually suffering
from cocaine addiction while he wrote
the screenplay explains a lot yeah but
yeah it's a Tony Montana as a Cuban
refugee who comes over and he is played
by that what a world-renowned Cuban
actor Al Pacino your clothes more
Hollywood like watches right and it's
it's a rags to riches type story rags to
very criminal Richard yes very criminal
riches it's in fact to the point of
obscene criminal riches the point that
he's got like this giant mountain of
cocaine on his desk at the end of and
he's just like periodically sticking his
face into it
I gotta makes you wonder if Oliver Stone
realized we was doing half way through
the script and decided to like self
reference it yeah maybe I'll at least
mention it so that people will know I'm
aware to put notes in the margin that
said make sure there's always cocaine
going on at any time you know that
anybody says anything
[Music]
there's a actually hilarious scene it's
a tragic scene but it's hilarious how
they there's the best gun yeah you know
Tony Montana is a is a paranoid
character and he's told his best friend
Stephen Bauer who's actually a Cuban
actor Lee but he's not using his real
name his he tells his friend like don't
don't ever go towards don't try for my
sister don't try ever at all
so like towards the end of the movie he
opens the door and he sees his friend
and she and he sees his sister like
dressed and dressing that they you know
they're living together they're living
in sin or whatever and he shoots he
shoots his best friend over it and she
comes down crying and everything's we
were going to tell you that we were
married and surprise you do you think
that he likes surprises like that do you
think that's the kind of guy you're
dealing with and like every time I see
this scene it's like oh that's tragic
and then when she says that I'm a
chicken I just laugh because it's like
you know who Tony Montana is there's no
reason for you to think that he'd love
this surprise surprises are everyone's
friends yeah exactly
[Music]
what do you think he's gonna serve us I
don't know what there's not let me I'm
trying to think about what kind of
dishes are in Scarface well it might be
I wouldn't be surprised to see you know
something bloody or rarest he does work
at a Cuban sandwich place at the
beginning so it could be Cuban sandwich
of some sort like from chef like from
chef and I would be totally down with a
Cuban sandwich that would be amazing
that would be amazing it's way better
than blood yeah it's way better
[Music]
oh my lord Moses yeah this looks amazing
oh my goodness yeah we got here okay so
we have a take on a robot yeah probably
has you know anywhere you go and cube I
just got back from Cuba anywhere you go
in Cuba probably has served and it's
generally done with beef but now at
these nice Pilates with these home
restaurants starting to use lamb just
trying to trying to think outside the
box a little bit so I kind of broke the
box so I put twit Inc in my robot vieja
braised and then to give it a little bit
of an acid punch I made a kind of a warm
escabeche of calamari to kind of bind it
with a squid ink so it's a bit of a surf
and turf but this this is a say hello to
my little lamb nice so it has that kind
of black-on-white vibe you know the
tucks the piquillo pepper I mean I don't
mean it to be gross but it's kind of got
that that blood stain on it bright red
and then I have this kind of almost like
a rum based vinaigrette that I put
around the dish that's kind of signifies
a mojito it's got basil it's got mint
because right now and Cuba they're using
a lot of basil strangely enough and the
mint just kind of goes with that Oh
mojito and lime vibe so there's a lot
going on here there's a lot of reasons
that all that stuff is there I don't
know if you need any more explanation
than that so this is lamb this is
braised lamb with squid ink in the
breeze with squid in the braids that's
right it was good oh good good yeah oh
my god great to hear I mean I've had
lamb before not had a lot of it the the
whole idea of doing Cuban food everyone
always says do pork
you know pork this pork that pork and
you know right now of course pork is
very prominent in keeping cooking but
I'm seeing a lot more lamb actually I
haven't been on the ground and I got to
like experience more what they're doing
there so this is very relative it's
pretty awesome to have an authentic
Cuban dish based on a movie with non
authentic Cuban air that is correct
that's right
this is really actually you know the
Basil's also there because Al Pacino's
Italian so there's a little bit of that
there's risotto on the plate instead of
rice you know these these are the little
things that you know that I that make me
happy it's a really good man it's me
knock it up making me happy as well and
would you like you man
this is got a unique flavor I don't had
anything like this I haven't either but
it also looks amazing yeah like
everything the perfect man looks look
beautiful it's almost like you knew they
were going to be filming this do my best
[Music]
thanks to Victor for the Cuban culinary
excellence make sure you head over to
the community table channel to hear more
from him and all the other chefs we have
to hang out with thanks for watching and
we'll see you next time on movie recipe
[Music]